the human civilization is advancing with
a truly uncanny speed
many technologies that have grown to
become virtually indispensable in our
everyday life seemed like fanciful
dreams just some hundred or even fifty
years ago
however all this progress is actually a
double-edged sword and the technological
development also resulted in pollution
and the depletion of natural resources
which is getting ever more acute every
year
mankind is growing desperate to get not
only rare metals and energy sources but
also seemingly trivial materials like
sand or water
the salvation from the oncoming natural
resources depletion crisis may probably
be found up in the sky
or more specifically in space which in
essence is a treasure trove of natural
resources
[Music]
between the orbits of mars and jupiter
there lies the asteroid belt
a vast area which is home to hundreds of
thousands of relatively small celestial
bodies
series a dwarf planet with a diameter
measuring slightly over 950 kilometers
is the largest of the lot
the rest of the space objects in this
part of the solar system are
considerably smaller
with some of them seen as potential
dwarf planets there is no doubt that
their overwhelming majority are
asteroids
according to data from february 2021
over a million celestial bodies of this
kind have been detected so far most of
which are located in the asteroid belt
the oort cloud is thought to contain by
far larger numbers of these but it is
too challenging to detect them due to
their small size and the distances
between us and them which are too great
these celestial objects may well be
numerous in the asteroid belt but their
mass total is not that great at
approximately 3 times 10 to the power of
21 kilograms
just to compare it is only 4 percent the
mass of the moon
according to the most widespread
classification all objects of this type
fall into three big groups carbonaceous
silicate
and metallic
the first group contains most asteroids
in fact roughly 75 percent of all known
asteroids in the solar system are c-type
these are made up mostly of graphite and
suit
the simplest modifications of carbon
by contrast silicate asteroids account
for approximately 17 of the overall
count these are rocky celestial bodies
made up of predictably enough silicate
varieties of rock
the other 8 of asteroids fall into the
category of metallic ones and these are
the most valuable from the point of view
of commercial exploitation and mining
as the name suggests metallic asteroids
are made up of metals and metal
compounds including those rare defined
on our earth the reason for this is that
as our planet was forming most heavy
elements like gold tungsten and platinum
were pulled to the center of the planet
by gravity forces there they formed a
massive core and mantle
only small amounts of these elements
remained at a comparatively small depth
where largely thanks to geological
processes they formed metalliferous
deposits
the largest known m-type asteroid psyche
with a diameter measuring roughly 186
kilometers
contains around 17 quadrillion tons of
metal ore
which is at least 20 000 times more than
all deposits of these resources that our
planet's crust is supposed to contain
even a comparatively small metallic
asteroid with a diameter of one
kilometer contains as much metal ore as
is extracted by all countries in the
world in the course of a year apart from
iron asteroids may be made up of
precious and rare earth metals like gold
and platinum the element indium which is
used in production of touch screens is
of special interest as well as extremely
rare osmium rhenium and rhodium
another important factor is great
amounts of water ice to be found in
asteroids water is not only
indispensable for life forms but is also
resource that oxygen may be produced
with
as for hydrogen extracted by splitting
water using the method of electrolysis
it may be used as fuel for spacecraft
as we can see small celestial bodies in
the solar system may potentially turn
out to be almost inexhaustible minds of
valuable natural resources but are we
technologically ready to carry out
prospecting and mining operations on
asteroids plans to extract natural
resources from space objects may appear
rather unreal
obviously mankind is not yet capable of
constructing a giant platform that would
capture and process one asteroid after
another
this does sound like a sci-fi movie
today
however projects of a smaller scale are
quite feasible even now
when plans are made to extract this or
that resource a factor to be reckoned
with is the ratio of the extraction
costs and the value of the resource
natural resources of our planet are
gradually getting depleted which means
that their value is inevitably and
inexorably going up
space technologies on the other hand are
getting cheaper which makes some
commercial space projects almost cost
efficient
most small celestial objects may well
line the asteroid belt but many are
still scattered across the inner part of
the solar system
hundreds of such-like objects get close
to the earth or collide with it every
year
as a rule they are relatively small
objects and cannot cause any serious
destruction
some of them are made up of tough rocks
or metals others contain substantial
amounts of water ice
if a heavy chunk of water ice like that
were to be captured and transported to a
desired spot it would potentially
satisfy the needs of the international
space station for many years to come
this is just one example of how
attractive and useful they can be
with all the obvious technological
shortcomings taken do you notice of a
number of projects already underway in
this field
one of these is the deep space
industries company also known as dsi
founded in 2013 it deals with designing
spaceships and propulsion systems some
claims made by the company
representatives may well sound fanciful
and presumptuous to mention but one dsi
promises to start mining natural
resources on an industrial scale and
asteroids close to the earth as soon as
this decade
the extracted materials are supposed to
be transported to the earth while it is
envisaged that in the future they will
be used actually in space for such
undertakings as construction works and
production processes away from our
planet
time will show whether these bold
projects will be put into practice
speaking about future plans for
exploration of small celestial bodies in
the solar system in general
there are three main approaches that can
be singled out
the first one involves extracting crude
ore and transporting it to a processing
point which may be either in space or on
the earth the advantage of this approach
is the option of employing automated
mechanisms that won't need to be mount
directly although on the downside
transporting large amounts of heavy
rocks is admittedly a rather complicated
and costly procedure
the second approach involves processing
extracted ore on site
both the volume and mass of the final
product will be considerably lower
whereas the transportation will be more
cost efficient with all useless waste
stroke successfully lost however in this
case another tough challenge will have
to be faced namely the construction of a
metal processing plant in space the
technological process of extracting pure
base metal out of ore requires both
great amounts of energy and additional
reagents like carbon or big volumes of
water
organizing the entire cycle of
production in such conditions may prove
to be quite a grueling ordeal
the third approach involves transporting
a celestial body to a processing plant
in space that would have been
constructed and prepared in advance
this centralized approach would solve
many of the issues implied by the
previous two although a certain
technological advancement is called for
for example space objects may be
transported by pinpoint blasting towing
or else using a pulse detonation engine
of some sort that will be mounted
directly on the transported body's
surface
unfortunately at this point of our
development mankind isn't capable of
transporting more or less significant
space objects
incidentally first experiments of this
kind are already in the pipeline for
example in the upcoming years the
european space agency is planning to
organize a collision between the small
near-earth asteroid dimorphous and a
man-made spacecraft the collision will
not only help to establish the
asteroid's makeup but also see how the
collision will affect its orbit
as for the technologies of tearing
things around in space eventually
they'll by all means develop and get
both cheaper and more reliable
processing extracted resources right
there in space implies that a large
orbital station has to be constructed
that would house dozens of people
in space a city like this will
inevitably encounter a number of issues
in terms of life support power supply
and last but not least trivial cooling
or smelting is carried out in extremely
high temperatures and heat dissipation
in a vacuum may prove to be a serious
issue
rare metals that are especially valuable
tend to be distributed rather unevenly
in iraq
their extraction from the rock and
purification involve exceptionally
elaborate technological processes
organizing complex production cycles at
a space plant like this as well as
maintaining its reliable and smooth
operation is hardly possible without a
considerable number of staff both
technical people and scientists residing
in orbit
having to create an environment suitable
for prolonged stays of large numbers of
people outside the earth must be
reckoned with and remains high on the
list of priorities
still i will repeat myself by saying
that technologies are constantly moving
forward at a breakneck speed and what
would appear to be unreal even yesterday
is already firmly establishing itself in
our today's life what we must remember
however is that the world needs care and
we must introduce ourselves to a
profit-seeking lot who are only after
the resources knowledge and living space
whether it is only our earth or the
entire solar system we must not harm or
destroy them in our search for resources
let's keep in touch
[Music]
you